Défilé d'Halloween, mon frère,
la seule nuit où nous nous sommes
intégrés, récupérez quelle partie et déplacez les ombres
, ne comprenez-vous pas que
je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel
avant les gars, j'ai une piste sur ce qui se passe
depuis que je frémis celui-ci était  toujours non,
nous devons être bons
tu es un rhinocéros et tu es hein je suis un
petit cochon
whoa eh bien
je suis Casey Jones tu fais les gars comme une chose
si le limon violet peut transformer les humains en
animaux il pourrait se transformer  nous
en humains, nous n'avons pas besoin d'être
coincés ici pour toujours s'il y a une chance
qui nous rend humains pour les tortues, que
vous le vouliez ou non,
préparez les gars
Oh,
cela ne fonctionne pas, nous continuons à
garder l'équipe unie et vous le ferez
toujours  réussir,
éclairons-le
Je ne sais pas si c'est un si bon plan
Novum devient doux avec moi maintenant
viens n'importe quel karabast eh
bien
ce qui se passe là-bas Donnie
n'a pas l'air bien vous êtes debout les gars
je récite des bogeys dans le bus je pense  c'est
très mordant bouton quel bouton il y a un
million de boutons
qu'est-ce que tu es super-héros  c'est
juste quatre frères qui détestent les intimidateurs et
aiment cette ville
quel est votre nom Casey Joe
êtes-vous les gars comme une chose à la recherche d'
Aaron ça va être bien
ramenez-le à Mohawk bon pour vous
vous avez tous des blagues hein
aller avec la tortue quand quelque chose  le mal
arrive tu veux être avec les tortues
prends le